[Music]
all right
welcome to the project management live
streaming session
my name is chandra chandra mr you can
call me cmr chandra whatever i saw i am
known as cmr because i have
various different practices on
enhancing the people's practices across
through a program called cmr excel i'm a
certified
itl v3 expert itl for managing
professional
pmp that is project management
professional prince2
prince2 agile princetoe
agile scrum master devops and kobit file
so today we are going to look at
understanding about what is project
management is all about
so this includes the topic includes
what is project management what is a
project
components of project management project
life cycle
key focus areas
[Music]
in project management then we will be
looking at understanding ah job roles in
project management
uh project management certifications uh
various different certifications we have
but one thing we should keep in mind is
while we go through this project
management
session we are not going to fully cover
on best practices of project management
like uh pmp framework or framework
defined backstage that is prince2
framework
so we understand uh and have a big
overview about what is project
management is all about
how does
any project management practitioner
should have in mind while getting into
project management profession
there may be certain way of doing
project management which i as a
practitioner have adopted and
doing and that correction can be made as
we get our own overview about what is
project management and what is that i
should know as a project manager
so answering the question what is
project management
so
project management by definition is
application of
knowledge skills tools
techniques and project activities
to meet project requirements
now any management for that matter is an
application of knowledge skills tools
and techniques to accomplish the
objectives like it may be a
service management it may be
quality management or it may be risk
management schedule management cost
management business man any management
relevant application application of
relevant skills knowledge and as a
manager who is playing the role of
management
may not do hands-on on it but i should
be fully aware of it
there is a lot of confusion among people
as a manager should i have should i be
an sme of the area where i am managing
obviously the background of that some
certain amount of experience of that is
required so that you can able to ask the
relevant questions and that will help
you in terms of reviewing the progress
of something
similarly project management itself is a
stream of practice to make projects
successful
but projects cannot be
of the same kind for example if i am
doing a project in it field versus
project i am doing in a civil
construction or maybe medical
so each of these technologies changes
the dynamics changes
and i as a project manager should be
able to understand those dynamics and
know the background of it otherwise i
cannot ask the relevant questions and
make that project successful
so this is the question which always
comes to the people so as a project
manager i get into management should i
be really technically strong
answer is yes
if not hands-on you should understand
the nitty-gritties of that particular
area in entirety so only then you can
able to make that project management uh
stuff or the kind of assignment you have
taken
successful otherwise what happens is you
are into that particular area where your
team is doing something you are unable
to ask the right questions and whatever
the team is explaining you are not
getting it will become like that so you
should do groundwork you should know
clear understanding about what exactly
we are going to implement for example i
am from uh telecom and i.t background if
i am doing
a civil construction project for example
a building has to be constructed i don't
know mixing of concrete how it is done
what is that combination i should do my
ground work
so it is not that we cannot do the
project if we are not from the domain
area but you should put effort before
you get into that project and understand
the
end-to-end requirement of that
right so
the objective of project management is
to make final deliverables in a finite
time and budget the moment if i say
finite time and budget it is fixed
so means it is
these are the constraints which we need
to keep in mind
while doing the project management so
obviously the resources you may speak
about human resources you may speak
about technology resources
but one thing which is very limited is
time if you set a target date before
this particular date it has to happen
obviously you need to have that
particular
timeline accomplished you should deliver
things within that time
if it is like a research project like
pandemic scenario we have come across
vaccination has to be given now do you
really have the time be constrained and
money definitely is something which is
required for any projects or any
investment or what organization does
that needs to be managed carefully
now every project definitely will have
the deliverables so the deliverables may
be
like
a product or a service or a just a
result for example if i'm manufacturing
cars in an automobile industry or if i'm
[Music]
doing some mobile phone manufacturing or
something like that so it is very uh
tangible in nature when i say product is
the output of a project very tangible in
nature
we can easily explain articulate and
visualize for example if you need to
make a training we may require to create
a training course material now that
itself is a project because it is not a
small thing
now the output is very clear visible to
us like microsoft office is a product
a chair table is a product so while we
make it we know by picture we know by
size with some measurement how does that
particular output look like if it is a
product very easy for us to visualize
but
as we say service is an output of a
project it is not so easy for us to
visualize unless we understand the
dynamics of the services
generally in
every training what i do whenever we
come across this term service as an
output of a project
people tend to have uh
stuck in the thought that helping is a
service or
service metrics what you use to measure
the performance of the service itself
people think as a output of a project it
is not for example we does
training as a service we do training as
a service
now unless i have i mean simple and has
a trainer a training content
a platform to present and people behind
working to make this training successful
until i have the processes people
technology everything in place i cannot
do training services
so when i say output of a project is
service a training services output of a
project in the sense i should build the
capability to do the training services
the building the capability is somewhat
what we are doing in the project
other example if i want to say like if i
am starting a restaurant services
i need to have a kitchen i need to have
a chef i need to have a billing system i
need to have a counter i have a dining
hall
i have a building space flooring
interior works once i complete all of
this
i would say i am ready to provide
restaurant services so as part of my
project where i am seeing services
output of a project
here i am building uh constructing or
refurbishing the entire
interiors of that particular space
recruiting people to serve to cook and
also creating that kitchen counters
billing system once all of this is ready
my restaurant is ready to do the
services so as part of project i make
all of these ready
so that's what the visualization one
should have
so when i create an output of a project
the output of a project can be
product or service or a result i said
but each of these involves configuring
in
resources in certain way
so in product you configure resources
and that itself is given to the
customer whereas in service
the ownership is never transferred
now if i
am an organization who manufacture
laptop
i sell this laptop and laptop is given
to the users
who are purchases this particular laptop
and the ownership is transferred
so user whoever purchases a laptop can
use whenever they want the way they want
whereas if i am providing this service
like restaurant service or this training
service or a taxi service any services
it will have a service window i can only
subscribe
i cannot own it
so ownership part when it comes to a
product it is transferred
whereas service ownership is never
transferred
the third type of output we are speaking
about results
so when i say output of a project is
result which is not a product which is
not a service we can take a simple
example of pandemic scenario where
in a specific area there are 1000
families living all of them needs to get
vaccinated
now what we can do
we can have a project
project to have all these thousand
families
vaccinated so that itself is a project
the result is
vaccinated citizens
or
out of thousand families only 800
families were vaccinated so this is a
result there is no a particular service
or there is no product which we built
here we we achieved certain uh target
what we are supposed to achieve like
senses we do
maybe we have taken a drive in the
organization to implement a
some new technology platforms so we've
implemented it created that result so
likewise output of a project would be
product service or result so
irrespective of the output definitely
all of these type of
outputs what we get in would have this
constraints relating to time budget
definitely so that we should be very
carefully understanding being the
project manager good understanding we
should have
so
similarly there are six constraints in
the project management we speak about
the six constraints would be
the scope
time
quality
cost risk and resources
so why do we call them as constraints
so any variation in any one of this
would have impact on other constraints
for example ah
if scope scope we have fixed when we
started the project we have told this is
what we need to accomplish the scope is
well
understood now as we progress further
because of some reason there is a change
change because of deviation change
because of uh business ask for the
change reason can be anything so to
modify that scope instead of doing 10
things let us do 12 things
so definite it will have impact on time
it will have impact on your cost
it introduces new risk
and you need
resources additionally do or do it then
quality would also something which you
need to look at to do the necessary
corrections so similarly you take any
constraints whether it is scope time
quality cost risk or resources
touching on any one of these constraints
and any variations whatsoever the reason
is
in any of these constraints will have an
impact on
other constraints which means project
manager
should be
measuring closely observing how these
are performing what is that we have
actually planned what what is our target
for all of these six constraints so
whatever the type of project you are
doing it may be a project which is
everything is fixed i am going like
waterfall model
a traditional waterfall model or you may
go in agile project management
approaches
in either of that
definitely these six constraints are
very important to look at and needs to
be managed carefully
so now speaking about
what is project now till now we
understood
project management and what are those
consideration one should have when we
speak about project management so we
spoke about what is project management
and while we do project management
what happens at the end of the project
like output of the project
product service or results we discussed
about
then we also understood about
constraints six constraints of the
project and how each of these
constraints will have an impact on other
constraints we discussed about that
now we will move to understand what is
project
right
so by definition
the way pmi defines the project as a
temporary end over
undertaken to create a unique product
service or result already i mentioned it
to you
the difference between product service
and result
the temporary nature of project
indicates a project has a definite
beginning and
the project may be of
four months
project may be of four years or ten
years
but definitely there will be one
specific
end
by accomplishing that objective our
project may also get close prematurely
why would any project closes prematurely
project closes prematurely because of
many reasons so budget is not there
business changed its directions
an organization is acquired by another
organization
like us many reasons
so
um
project will have an end but basic
basically when you look at project
maintenance by default by completing
all that objectives by accomplishing all
that objectives
so the main intent is that i took up a
project business has initiated or
invested on certain things and this
project to accomplish certain specific
objectives
to create a product or to create a
result or to create a service
whatsoever it is the moment the project
is taken while taking definitely we as
an organization
should do uh the the reason behind why
are we taking this project that analysis
has to be done
so once that is justified yes we need to
take up this project so whatsoever the
justification is once the project is
taken up
so then you will be having that project
objective accomplished that's what the
idea so only by accomplishing that
objective you will say project is
completed that is a very idealistic
scenario but there are many scenarios
where project may end
prematurely so before you complete that
particular objective of the project or
the output or results of the project
without achieving it also you can close
the project and various different
reasons as i mentioned
so we need to know it is temporary
project is always temporary and this
should not be confused with operations
business as usual
like if i speak about
an operator watching uh some performance
of something like for example let us
take cloud services
someone is watching the performance of
that particular cloud platform
that person comes every day and does the
same thing
check the same set of parameters and see
anything is
going as per the plan or is any
deviations and any deviations
initiate that correction corrective
actions and many preventive actions are
taken which are regular basis regularly
will be doing the same thing but project
is not like that
you have a specific output to be
accomplished specific results
and accordingly uh you will have a
beginning where the project get
triggered initiated and you end the
project by accomplishing that objective
ideally that's how it is and project
doesn't exist once you are completed
objective or as you declare the closure
of the project project is non-existent
from that
right so this we need to keep in mind
project is temporary
it has the beginning it has an end
then
it produces unique output like product
service or results
and then
it has risks and projects have
uncertainties
i told about premature closure because
of the uncertainties project may get
pretty close that is also one
possibility
one important thing what we should keep
in mind is
every project introduces change to the
environment
[Music]
so for example if i have
refurbished or
did an interior works to a place
earlier it was in a different shape now
it is in a
new state which is a change what is
being introduced
uh someone gets into a
journey of
enabling the employees
into certain certification program let
me say your organization to recall that
at least 25 employees in my organization
should get certified in some specific
technology certification or practice
certification
which is non-existent now once that
project is taken up
after all the 25 people are certified
the change is introduced to environment
now this is a change what is coming
so project introduces change to the
environment in a way project management
is a change management so that you
should keep in mind
okay so
that's about uh project
so in summary when i say project
project is temporary in nature project
introduces change
it has risks it produces unique outputs
product service or
results it has a specific start and
specification
so project has six constraints which we
saw in project management that is
time budget
then
resource
quality
risk
so now we will move to understand what
is project life cycle
so when i use the term life cycle it's
always like beginning and end
while we looked at definition of project
we understood project as a
beginning and end so anything which has
the beginning will have an end means it
has a life cycle
we have human beings
also have life cycle we take birth and
there is death
if you look at a medicine or any product
there is an expiry date mentioned
so the date of manufacturing
and date of expiry means that product
has a life cycle
similarly service
now postal service if i take an example
where we used to have we were writing
letters to people
today we send sms or whatsapp messages
or emails
so that postal service of that nature is
non-existent we are not using it
whereas
messaging service has been replaced by
technology
the need of that particular service is
there but the way we fulfill changes
means service also have the life cycle
so every product have a life cycle every
service has a life cycle similarly
project also have the life cycle so in
the life cycle of a project
we speak about
five
areas mainly so initiation planning
execution monitoring
and closure now before we go and
understand each of these
regarding the relationship between
project life cycle
and product life cycle if we need to
understand
[Music]
let us assume
a product like a mobile app when we
create we take up a project
so we took up a project as an
organization
created a mobile app
and output of that project is mobile app
itself means we created a product a
platform
so in this case project life cycle ended
in creation of
a specific
platform a mobile app an application a
specific product
so project life cycle ended there after
creation of a specific
product
whereas product life cycle started from
there
i'll repeat this a project
has been taken up to create a mobile
application
the output of that project is that
mobile application itself
a product
so project life cycle of creating that
mobile application ended there
we initiated a project to create that
product and we ended that life cycle
from there product life cycle of mobile
application started
now as the product life cycle of mobile
application exists
we keep updating that
we keep modifying that product to modify
to add features to delete features we
may take up the projects
so in a product life cycle
there are multiple project life cycle
may come up so now i need to take off
this particular product
for that also i will initiate a project
so in a product life cycle or a service
life cycle
minimum two projects are involved one
project is for creating the product
other project is for retiring that
project or moving away from the existing
setup
two projects minimum in between the life
cycle of the product life cycle
you may have many projects initiated to
modify update
or add new features features
functionalities etc into that product
and same holds true for service life
cycle also in a service life cycle
at least you will have two projects
initiated one is i'll initiate by
introducing that service and well
removing that service so two project
life cycles in between the service life
cycle you may have many projects
initiated
means in a product life cycle or in a
service life cycle you can have multiple
project life cycles so this picture you
should have it is not otherwise
now speaking about this
five areas like initiation planning
execution monitoring and closure
many people call them as stage or phases
which is not correct
we don't call initiation stage planning
stage execution stage monitoring stage
or closure stage because they exist
throughout the life cycle for example i
initiate a stage of a project
i can say i initiate a project similarly
i can say i initiate a stage of a
project similarly i can say i have
initiated creation of some feature
similarly i can say initiated an
activity meaning
each of these are existing throughout
the project life cycle
particularly so if i'm initiating
something parallelly i may be executing
something else
so project will not have the stages like
initiation stage planning stage
execution stage
instead it will have stage 1 stage 2
stage 3 stage 4 like that
so that is based on what kind of output
i am going to create
what kind of project i have taken up
based on that you will create a stage if
i am constructing a multi stored
building i will have multiple stages
like
the ground floor setup is one stage
and then having pillars constructed as a
second stage then wall constructions and
sealing as a third stage likewise i can
make stages based on the deliverables
and each of these stages will have all
of this initiation planning execution
monitoring and closure similarly within
that a specific deliverable would have
initiating planning execution
monitoring and closure
so when i say initiation
initiation is the step for checking the
feasibility
and measuring the worth of product so
you check the feasibility should we take
up this project should we not take up
this project
what is that we are going to accomplish
by doing this project so pre-project
stage also the initiating or trigger of
project would happen so we create a
business case we discuss with the
business stakeholders
and decide should we take up this
project or not
now interesting part is before
deciding on any specific initiative to
be taken up
there may be multiple options we will
have
there will be opportunity statement
or there may be problem statement
to address it we may have multiple
options or multiple solutions
so which solution is best for me
that we need to decide so whichever the
solution we decide
then you will further analyze that
whether this particular solution is
worthwhile to take up and move out you
justify you justify comparing with other
solutions
and also once one solution is actually
selected or suggested recommended
taking that particular solution you
further analyze it in detail
before you go and decide i will take up
this project
so this is how projects get initiated so
one would check the feasibility
measure the worth of the project
should we do this or not
so that is about initiation
now speaking about planning
now
planning is all about to say like
waterfall model we speak about in end to
end we will plan
fixed plan
a blueprint we will have if it is agile
kind of thing you will have a skeleton
planning at the higher level and then as
you progress
progressively you will do planning you
keep updating that plan right
so
you create a blueprint and this
blueprint would be something which you
would be referring throughout the
project life cycle
to check how things are
progressing
and
that will become a reference point as
you execute and deliver you check back
am i delivering as we planned
now this is uh this will become tedious
exercise if something
has a change requires a change as you
progress in the project
in a scenario where multiple changes are
coming uncertainties are high changes
are keep coming
then going with the fixed plan will be
always challenging
that's where in the
modern business environment if you see
we are speaking about
agility more and more what is agile
agile is all about being flexible
adaptable
change to the changing conditions
moving faster this is what we speak
the more the uncertainties are
you would become a child lesser than
uncertainty you will have a detailed
plan for example i am going to construct
a house for myself
it can be very well planned initially
and then we can go minor variations can
come in but not too much
but look at today's projects what we
take up like projects uh where we have
this uh
mobile app kind of thing as an example
what we do or any of the civil
construction we today we are seeing like
uh flyover constructions it is very
agile every modules are made and that is
fixed in the site manufacturing happens
in some other place
so meaning the amount of flexibility
amount of uncertainty increases you may
require to look at agile way of doing
things so project management
actually considers the need of the
agility similarly waterfall means
everything is predictable we call it as
adaptable which is agile predictable
which is waterfall
model so planning dynamics goes
accordingly
right so we while we plan definitely we
should have a detailed understanding
about the requirements what is that we
are going to accomplish
so what requirements are we speaking
about
now user customers will have a
requirement
to fulfill that you have a solution
now to accomplish this solution then
some requirement has to be achieved
solutions requirement
now for these solutions then further you
have some
resources or some constraints what we
spoke about requirements associated with
that
then to measure the performance of it
you need to have a measurement methods
and metrics again the requirements
associated with that so like with
multiple level of requirements needs to
be analyzed while you plan
so this planning may include planning
related to
technology planning related to process
planning related to resources
including human resource and technology
resources
measurement methods and before
measurement methods what should be
measured how should we measure what
metrics make sense
right then reporting and reviewing so
people ignore this part metrics they
consider but they ignore on reviewing
part
what should be reviewed whenever it has
to be reviewed what is that expected
results should be
so that people miss out so that we
should be very careful while planning
you should you cannot miss out on
planning part you should hundred percent
consider that
in entirety right from requirements
which is expressed by stakeholders two
solutions
to uh
technology resources then processes etc
then methods of measuring and metrics
and reviewing so planning should be into
it that visualization should be there
so many time people think project
manager coordinates
coordination is the only way i do
management pro management is not about
coordination
coordination and communication is
essential in management which plays very
critical role crucial role
but that itself is not project
management
so right from initiation the project
management thought starts so that should
be clearly visible project manager we
call it as an integrator
if i take pmp as an example we spoke
about we speak about project integration
management
which basically project manager should
have an end-to-end view of the project a
bird's-eye view
so
saying that i'm a bird i cannot keep
flying at the very high
and then keep flying that will not work
so as a project manager should come down
see what is the ground reality then go
up see what is that variations can be
seen
so that action should keep happening so
coordination is required to understand
what is the on ground realities at the
same time going and evaluating with the
subject matter experts and you yourself
with your ability to analyze things
going up and checking those that is very
important
so only then planning will become very
effective and that results in
execution not having any issues a very
good planning always results in
hassles free execution you may not have
any issues with execution
hundred percent i cannot say that
um you will have no issues during
executions on ground realities which is
not seen unseen by us may come across so
who who actually
visualized the pandemic scenario how
many of us thought that after
pandemic has come in the all of us will
be working from home
we will be relying on the technology we
never thought about it so that amount of
uncertainties definitely remain so
whatever the amount of detailing you go
in anything
definitely there will be some amount of
uncertainty remains which are unknown to
us
so that will come up during execution so
but only thing mentally
and
you as well as your team should be ready
to handle them and you should keep
analyzing this very carefully
so execution involves allocation of
resources and making of the deliverables
means you have a plan
so as per the plan you are acquiring the
resources you are confirming the
configuring that resources
and then implementing them and there is
a deliverable
now while we do this
very important thing is checking did we
accomplish what we actually intended to
accomplish
now what is that internet accomplish
where will you know that
obviously in planning
now last part of planning i told you
reviewing measuring consideration of
metrics metrics are just a number
but that number should have an
interpretation
we cannot just leave with the number as
number
so in parallel that should happen as i
execute i am checking is the performance
is happening as we planned is the
deliverable is going as we need that is
very important
so then you do monitoring so execution
monitoring go hands in hand
so you may require to ensure right
metrics are considered to measure
so
this involves monitoring and controlling
of working of project
now project manager
while uh
execution is happening definitely
who is executing what is being executed
what deliverable should come out of that
at what point in time at what budget
those definitely needs to be look those
things needs to be looked at carefully
but at the same time performance of the
deliverable how is this performance
what is that deliverable is how this
deliverable is actually looking like
what is that intended output was as we
planned did that happen
and the performance is it happening
accordingly is there anything which we
can think of further improvising or
modifying to the next level enhancing to
the next level with the constraint
within the constraints what we have
so likewise so we may require to ensure
in monitoring and control we have
something defined already in terms of
metrics
in terms of measurement methods in terms
of templates in terms of process
in terms of technology we have defined
everything but that needs to be action
actioned as per the plan
at the same time considering the
dynamics of the current scenario very
important so one needs to be very
alert on what the variations what is
happening so one is to monitor and
control that working of the project
regularly
and project managers active presence
during the monitoring is very very
important and
because of this one should not think
that project manager is only doing
monitoring and controlling so why does
anyone think project manager only do
coordination project manager only does
ask questions
project managers comes and takes the
inputs and just goes back so why is that
what is that they are thinking by this
so
the problem here is
while project manager is monitoring and
controlling that's when project manager
works closely with the team on ground
otherwise project manager is not seen by
the team
generally project manager will be with
smes project manager will be with the
business stakeholders
project manager will be with the
customers project manager will be in the
different different sites at a different
different time so because of these
variations team fields only when
manager comes in
reviews monitors and controls checks so
it looks like coordination which is not
true but this is very important and very
very essential thing without this one
cannot assure or one cannot confirm
the accomplishment of the
requirements
that's about monitoring
then speaking about closure so closure
is not one time thing
closure happens throughout the project
life cycle
so as we
take up certain
[Music]
accept certain requirement from the
stakeholders
now we do analyze of the analysis of
that we create a project charters in
initiation part of it
the completion of project charter
handing over of the project charter and
declaring the assignment of project
management so formally that activity
gets closed closure is involved there
also
similarly in each of the life cycle in
the entire life cycle of the project you
have certain deliverables being done
okay formal completion of the
deliverables yes it is done there should
be formality which one has to do that is
also closure
at the end of phases you do closure
activity at the end of the deliverables
you will do the closure activity
so likewise
closure
is a stage of the project it's
definitely happens in final stage of
project but
everywhere across the project during the
project life cycle you keep confirming
and closing them
right so while you do that
obviously one has to understand whether
everything is complete as per the
requirements means monitoring and
controlling
should confirm yes everything is happen
according to what we need
so
closure is the final stage of the
project for sure but it is the final
thing of
everything what we do
if i am planning there is a end for the
planning if i am executing something
there is n for that execution as well
right
one moment i think
[Music]
yeah
is it okay now
i guess it's okay
all right so
uh as we close certain things as we
accomplish certain results as we
complete certain uh
activity we initiate that closure part
of it we close them formally
so that's about closure so initiation
planning execution
monitoring and controlling and closure
many times people think after execution
we can just jump into closure which is
not true you cannot jump into closure
immediately after execution it has to
pass through monitoring and control
assume during monitoring and control
something did not work
something did not go as per the plan
that requires correction
so that correction definitely has to go
back to execution or again if you
require certain planning being done you
may require to do it
and then you would further
close it
after completion of that particular
thing as per the plan fully
so that's about closure then key focus
areas in the project management so what
are the key focus areas in the project
we look at that
so till now we looked at what is project
management
we understood what this project
and we also looked at various different
areas in the project management we
discussed about life cycle also life
cycle broad product life cycle service
life cycle project life cycle we
discussed
now let us look at focus areas in the
project management
so key focus areas as i mentioned about
six constraints
obviously scope schedule cost quality
resources
stakeholder
so each of these areas are very
essential so engagement should happen to
handle all of this
so very critical if any one of these
areas some failure
things may not go in the directions
required
so for example if i say scope what is
scope
now scope you can visualize like a
boundary
right by definition it refers to inputs
property to take the project from the
step first step to last step
which determines features boundaries
budget deadlines of the project
now broadly if i look at the scope we
can you can look at the scope of the
output the deliverable
versus scope of those activities
scope of that
actions processes required resources
required
to accomplish that results or
deliverables
so if i am creating a
laptop which is an output of a project
i should speak about laptop
configuration
laptops features functionality
measurement of the size of the laptop
so all these are scope of the product
scope of the output
now to do this
to
bring this as an output of a project
i am required to have a
motherboard
keyboard touchpad
or a display system all of this needs to
be integrated in certain way
correct so these resources i need
and each of these resources will have a
specifications
and all of these resources has to be
taken
configure them in certain way
right only then i will have a laptop as
an output
so one is the scope of the product
itself other one is the resources
required the features functionality
specification of that particular
resources
and the process of creating them and the
resources required to create them all
this comes under project scope
so broadly you can visualize this
product scope then project scope so
without product scope means scope of
that output you cannot have the project
scope
so it starts from that output what i am
going to create scope of that particular
output what i am creating
and what is that resource process
required so that's what falls under
project scope which we need to manage to
accomplish that results as we planned
next is about schedule
so schedule is about timeline what we're
speaking about the time of beginning
time it ends
what activity for right from if you look
at the project end to end there is a
timeline
if you look at a specific
activity to start there is a timeline if
you look at the process to start and
then there is a timeline likewise
a plan for performing specific work
within particular time interval and
achieving the desired objective the
schedule refers to the start date and
finish date and the duration of the
project
now there are two things what we speak
about duration and effort
now if i say to create certain thing it
requires
100 human days 100
under human days of effort is needed but
in how many days i can do it i should do
it in 25 days 25 days a duration
now meaning in each day how many uh
how much of effort i should put in here
man days or human days of kind of thing
so meaning 2500 divided by 25 at least
four mandates of effort i should put so
that in 25 working days i can have a
hundred mandates of
effort being put
so that need to analyze many times you
may see variations in this also because
of the variations in the resources
skills and capabilities
what you have in the
system
so schedule variation will happen
because of that so it should be
carefully understanding and handling
so this has a timeline the timeline is
for deliverable
but the required resources process has
to happen accordingly so this may get
impacted because the available resources
is not as per what we required the
timeline is different i wanted today but
it is delayed by three days
it cannot happen that needs to be
handled very carefully and
they require certain proactiveness to
handle it
then cost
definitely there is an investment to be
done every project doesn't bring revenue
please keep this in mind we don't use
the terminology revenue when we speak
about the money factor relating to
project
it's always cost
which is a money which is outgoing
one is a cost it's always outgoing thing
so that we need to estimate we need to
have a funding for that there needs to
be action taken every now and then to
ensure that with that this project is
happening within that uh budgeted value
right so only then you can justify
i wanted to have a product which with
100 whatever the currency and i have a
plan of my business case i'm speaking
about so i have a plan of selling this
for 125 each
piece so now 25 i'm assuming is a profit
if i don't do the project within android
and it has become 110 now i lost profit
there
in the business perspective
so similarly if it becomes 130 it
doesn't make sense for me to do that
project at all
so likewise so business justification is
very essential and budgeting
consideration is not just about to do
this project it takes so much it is not
just about that
for business is it making sense that is
another thing considering all of that
the budget is actually allocated to the
project so you as a project manager
should understand what is the background
of this project
why the project was triggered and what
are the constraints they have so unless
you understand that you cannot take the
project to the required direction
and cannot do within that particular
allocated budget
speaking about quality quality is about
meeting the requirements what is being
defined so every deliverable will have
specifications
every process will have a matrix every
resources will have certain metrics to
look at
so quality has to accomplish those
qualities about all about accomplishing
the different requirements
to set high grade low grade irrespective
of that whatever the grade is said you
may require to accomplish accordingly
so it includes the processes activities
that are to perform to meet objectives
and requirements for it for which it was
undertaken
so for this you may do audit you may do
testing you may do quality assurance
quality control
that should be in place one cannot
ignore that part
then uh to do any of this you need
resources it may be technology resource
it may be human resources etc
who help in carrying out specific
activities or tasks in the project in
the best possible manner
it can be people equipment funds
facility
whatever
needed for accomplishing the project
requirements
now resources we estimated fine but
availability of that resources at a
specific point in time is very important
at a specific point in time it cannot be
delayed if i want to have a resource a
certain point in time yes i want to have
the resource exactly at that point in
time i cannot delay if that delays
obviously it will have a direct impact
on your quality
direct impact on your cost can you
all other constraints
then stakeholders stakeholders plays
very important role in the project who
can be the stakeholders
all that
entities individuals
who are around the project
who will get influenced impacted
directly indirectly and they will also
have an impact and influence directly
indirectly
for example if i'm doing the project of
constructing a
bridge i fly over for example
who are the stakeholders here i cannot
just say a government agency is a
stakeholder the team who is doing the
project is a stakeholder i cannot just
limit my thought to that the citizens
who are living in that area
they are very important stakeholders
similarly uh the people who commute
regularly even though they are not
living there they commute regularly so
they are the stakeholders so likewise we
need to stakeholders exist internally as
well as external to the organization so
we should ensure each of the
stakeholders
and their dynamics are understood and
what kind of engagement we should have
this with have with these stakeholders
how regularly we should have that
engagement with these stakeholders
what are the needs of the stakeholders
that needs to be understood and your
engagement should ensure you are
fulfilling those
accordingly right so stakeholders are
the ones who have an interest in the
deliverables of project they can be part
of project team project managers
sponsors customers and user in simpler
way
but it is beyond maybe an organization
it may be
an individual for example uh
when when you
attend this training session for example
you register for some training session
with simply learn and you are attending
the training
now can we call the family member of the
participant as a stakeholder
answer is yes
to what extent simply learn doesn't
manage them but definitely consider them
as a stakeholder who are very distant
not near so participant will instruct
the participant please mute yourself so
there should not be any disturbance
that way for simple number in simpleness
perspective the stakeholder is far
need not do anything simpler need not do
anything but recognize and instruct the
participants please mute there may be
noise from your end
but when it comes to the scenario where
the participants perspective if you look
at that stakeholder is near to the
participant direct impact
so stakeholder has to do something that
particular participant in their context
to make their training successful then
to do something inform the family
members or ensure you're sitting in a
silent place where you can concentrate
fully and involve likewise
so that way
identification of stakeholders analyzing
on what kind of engagement we should
have this with stakeholders what is the
requirement of stakeholder relating to
this project
while you do this
it is very contextual as a project
manager i look at the stakeholders in my
projects perspective
so a customer
member
with whom i am conversing every day
the context of that being a project
manager i will have an engagement in
certain way whereas my team member a
project team member the context will
change while they engage with that
particular person
so that dynamics one needs to understand
we cannot make it very
same kind of description of stakeholder
for a different context as the context
changes
the dynamics of stakeholders changes and
also the way it engages stakeholder will
also change please keep this in mind and
you may require to educate this to your
team members also
being a project manager
so all right this is about key focus
areas in the project management
so
seventh communication as i mentioned
communication and collaboration
plays a very important role while we
have this
project management so once i think one
of the services 90 to 95 percent of the
times
project manager keeps communicating
project manager needs to communicate it
is very essential
so
a communication ability
a
ability of a project manager to
communicate plays a very important role
very critical very crucial
so one needs to keep this in mind so you
should practice your communication you
cannot ignore
many times you see that my performance
will speak i need not speak that will
not work
as we see in a sales and marketing where
customer engagement and
regular interactions matters
similarly in project management is very
essential
for the success of the project the
communication should will play its role
so it may make or break the project we
should be careful accordingly
right so communication among all
stakeholders is an essential aspect of
project management for successful
project execution improving
communication increases the
relation of success and decreases the
probability of risk
now risk many pa times we speak with the
negative context so definitely risk is
not about negative alone but here it is
spoken in a negative context
so risk is positive also please keep
that in mind
then coming to risk
so risk is all about an uncertainty
an unexpected event
so for example we are doing this session
in what probability the power would go
off and what probability internet would
fail in what probability the platform
itself would go down
there is some probability we cannot say
hundred percent will not go down we
cannot say there is probability
so to the extent of that probability we
have the uncertainty
so when it becomes a reality
when that fails
when that occurs
then it is an event to manage
it's an incident to manage
so meaning whenever i use the term risk
it is always in the future
next moment the power may fail still it
is in future
so it is uncertain
uncertainty
something which you are having an impact
on whatever we are doing it may be
positive impact it may be negative
impact
so what can be positive risk example now
i thought i will have around
250 people coming into the session and
uh
interestingly i have 75 people
participate in the session out of which
um
all the 75 registered for training
good thing positive risk that is
uncertainty actually
so i expected uh 30 people 50 people to
70 people came in and all the 75
registered for trading positive thing
uncertainty
can i rule out on that
no that probability also exists positive
risk
so if 75 people came only 10 people
registered that is also kind of
uncertainty negative
right so it may be related to the
project people technology
resources
right so we our aim should be identify
our risk throughout the project life
cycle
and ensure that each of these risks are
analyzed and risk is very dynamic
as you progress in the project life
cycle
the impact
the probability of occurrence of that
keeps varying
right so because earlier it was nothing
was there in the place as you kept doing
the project you introduced many thing
into the
environment and that brings in new kind
of risks so that you should be very
careful analyzing and handling it
that's about risk then procurement
everything we do
involves procurement
we procure for example for this session
we have the document of internet for
example
so every project every business what we
do procurement is involved so project
managers should be well aware of what
are those we are procuring
there should be decision on make or buy
right before when you start the project
i'm going to buy this means i have to
purchase this
i will make myself this particular
portion depending on our subject matter
expertise
so since we're speaking about
procurement obviously we may require to
know what are the processes relating to
procurement in our organization
and i as a project manager cannot become
a procurement manager but i need to know
who is the procurement manager and
engage with the procurement manager
accordingly and i should comply to the
process i cannot deviate so that
awareness should be there
then critical success factors
when we say critical success factor
obviously it refers to
the area the factors which we need to
consider to measure so once i accomplish
these factors these objectives
i am i become successful in this project
critical success factor now each of the
critical success factor should have the
kpis key performance indicators
so i need to have metrics to measure
that's what key performance indicators
are so each of the critical success
factors
should have the kps to measure and once
we accomplish that matrix we can say we
have completed key success critical
success factor what can be critical
success factor for a training as an
example
all the topics planned are completed
that is critical success factor now what
can be kpa
five topics i have planned i completed
all the five topics
kpix
right so it should have a measurement
and what is that i am going to
interpret
perceive
while measuring this particular matrix
that's what critical success factor
would be speaking about
then speaking about deliverables
obviously we spoke about it multiple
times which is an output of the project
which may happen
regularly throughout the project life
cycle
and
it can be
have externally
or
internally
depending on what kind of project you
have i've taken a taken of a project
which is very internal to my
organization so you have internal
stakeholders and the deliverables
happening from this will be having
implementation internally
in the organization whereas external i
may deliver it to external customer
so as i mentioned earlier that scope of
the deliverable product scope should be
very clear
then what breakdown structure
as we know what is the deliverable
as we understand what needs to be
accomplished we also spoke about having
list of things like what needs to be
done what process we need what resource
we need
once we have that list of things
only then we can action them put them
into action and deliver them for that i
need to have a detailed thing so we do
decomposition top down decomposition of
the items for example if i take a laptop
again and take an example ease of
visualization
if i do the breakdown of laptop which is
product breakdown first always or break
down like hardware and software first
then hardware part or breakdown like
keypad
touchpad body display likewise i will
separate them
further breakdown i would do for each of
this
so likewise i do the product breakdown
first
then from bottom up i keep adding
resources effort cost
risk everything analyze and i consult it
so entire thing we call it as work
breakdown structure so without work
breakdown structure one cannot have a
deliverable visualized properly
and what is that effort is involved what
is the cost involved visualizing that in
entirety will become challenging
then job roles in the project management
so till now we understood what is
project management what is project
project life cycle product life cycle
outputs of project
constraints of project then we spoke
about
key factors of project management
now let us look at what are the job
roles typically we come across
so job roles can be steering committee
member a project manager senior project
manager project lead
resource manager resource management
office analyst
now project manager as we know who takes
up the project
owns that in entirety
lead and ensure that
project is accomplishing the required
results so project manager has to manage
review prioritize
and tasks whenever wherever required
and which involves all the six
constraints we spoke about and all the
deliverables so typically based on the
survey in the market as a kind of
salary what a project manager can
expect is actually
mentioned here it is indicative actually
it is not absolutely that number it will
have its own variations depending on
the kind of
domain area the project is being done if
i am doing a project management for a
cloud infrastructure versus i am doing a
project for a civil construction huge
difference right depends on industry
also
a type of technology related project for
example i'm working on a project for
satellite launch dynamic is different
so it would vary accordingly
and it applies to all the trolls what i
mentioned so whatever the number is
mentioned it's on an average what we
found in the market is mentioned
so speaking about senior project
management manager
so head off whole project management
plan
may be having handling
bigger projects complex projects
not the simplest ones maybe senior
person having a very good experience and
expertise across
right
and
the salary would vary like
along with allowances and bonuses
and
for example
one of the projects i i have done like
work style innovation i'll not mention
the organization
so this is a global organization where
we have required to bring everything
into same platform
so
even though a
managing director was a designation of
the person who was a project manager for
that project who was working on the role
of project management for this
particular project
so like this complexity of the project
matters accordingly it takes so not
speaking about that complexity when as a
senior project manager i just gave an
example of that kind of
speaking about project lead
so one who leads the people throughout
the project and provide them with all
the information required throughout
engages with team
motivates team
helps project manager assist project
manager in various different ways
creates the registers maintain the
registers update the registers etc
so
here the particular salary perspective
look at it looks like
what is given there
which is lesser than project manager
obviously
then
resource manager so human resource what
we're speaking about
who would actually looks at assigning
the people to the project managing
employees within the project assignment
and then giving that details of what
role has to be done by that particular
resource
and their salary variations would look
like this
then uh if i look at the
next role that is project management
office analyst
pmo
right so works within the pmo and does
most of the data driven work
so analyzing and interpreting data
concerning the project figuring out
future risks to the project finding new
ways to advance the idea of project
management so typically this role what
happens is
working within the pmo setup where pmo
will have visibility to multiple
projects so the inputs what is provided
by this pmo analyst would actually help
in optimizing resources optimizing cost
and sharing of the resources across the
project likewise
it helps in a lot in the project program
management as well
so then steering committee member
so member of this committee would work
as work on the project themselves
uh help they help the project manager in
various different conditions by
providing the inputs on the projects
on the budget what is being used what is
not uh
utilized where do we stand in the
project perspective and any feedbacks
which comes up
for the questions from the project
managers steering committee member would
be providing those and this is the
salary which you can
these are the few roles what we
actually
captured it doesn't mean only these many
roles are there if you look at we have
not even spoken about the roles in agile
project management kind of scenarios
so definitely that has a different
dynamics and different set of rules
so then various different certifications
what we have industry recognized
certification global electronic
certification for project management
so we can speak about pmp that is
project management professional
we have a gel certified practitioner
which is pmacp again offered by bmi
then capm certified associated project
management again from pmi then certified
scrum master
prince2 or from xbox
then speaking about pmp project
management professional this
certification is offered by a pmi
so training partner definitely simple
and will do the training in all of that
certification area we mentioned
and this particular certification
examination cost examination fraction
and duration of the examination
mentioned here
now this examination pattern where we
are seeing 200 multiple choice questions
i think we may we i think we are missed
to update that it is 180 questions 230
minutes duration of the examination not
four hours really
four hours comes to 240 minutes it is
230 minutes and 180
questions in the latest pattern from
from the date a new version has been
released
so uh otherwise the exam fee remains 4.5
dollars for pmi member and 550 for pmi
non-member
so examination will have 180 multiple
choice questions and duration will be 2
30 minutes
then
prerequisite
to take up this particular examination
one should have an experience
of
36 months so three years if i say
we are trying to indicate about 36
months
and that 36 months need not to be
continuous if there will be break in
between no issues multiple projects or
single project doesn't matter
and
34 hours of project management education
right
if someone is not a graduate a
bachelor's degree graduate holder that
person need to have
60 years of project management
experience and sorry 60 years of project
professional experience and
that requires again the education part
of its remains certified contractors
and after certification that is valid
for three years
and you may require to renew the
certificate by producing 60 pdus 60
videos has to be on through two ways
actually by
getting new certification new areas of
education i think that that
understanding you'll get thoroughly when
you go through pmp training
and other 24 videos may come across like
giving back to the project management
thing so you go through that whenever
you get into a pmp training you will
have a detailed understanding of that
and speaking about agile certified
practitioner again offered by pmi
to bring in the project agile aspects
into project management so one one thing
you should keep in mind when we say
agile agile is not just about project
hl can be applied in business as usual
operations also
so keeping that in mind when we say
agile
certified practitioner acp pmasap in the
project context
so this is being depicted
so otherwise agile practices can be put
into any
practices like
in my business as usual also i can
practice agile
so exam fee exam duration and pattern is
given so now prerequisite perspective
two thousand hours of project management
experience
fifteen hundred hours agile experience
and twenty one contact hours of feature
practices of this one education
so 30 pds
every three years and for renewing that
certificate
speaking about capm so someone who does
not have
a big experience in the project
management they can go for capm
and
this does not have
does not ask for any big experience as
such
the examination is of 150
questions and three hours
so prerequisite is about pmp education i
mean that's a capm uh training as a
prerequisite that's what no project
management experience is expected
and then examination has to be taken
every three years well it is again three
years here as well
speaking about certified scrum master
so this is an entry level certification
which helps practitioner to understand
what is the scrum master role is all
about what is scrum framework is all
about
and then this is the certification from
scrum alliance right so exam fee
again
exam can be taken in a training
institute itself so institute institute
it would vary
so 16 hours 2 days training and 50
multiple choice questions examination
duration will be 60 minutes
then there is no prerequisite as such
so any one has to study the certificate
every two years
speaking about projects in controlled
environment prince2 this is from extra
loss
these certifications come from axelos uk
based well pmi is the us-based
xlos is uk based and both pmp and
prince2 has its own
value by itself
and this uh
certification is of two levels one is
foundation another one is practitioner
so foundation level certification that
doesn't require any prerequisite as such
whereas uh
practitioner level of examinations
required foundation certification is
prerequisite so examination is of 60
minutes for foundation 150 minutes for
practitioner
and you will have 60 questions in
foundation there are 68 questions in
practitioner all right so 20 cpds per
year one has to earn based on that every
three years the certification can be
renewed otherwise one has to take the
examinations again
so that's about
what is project management session i
hope this has given you some insight
about what is project management what is
project
what are the constraints in the project
what are the key factors in the project
then difference between project life
cycle and product life cycle
various different roles in the project
management
and then various different
certifications offered by simple learn
as well as the project management
certifications available
and support me from my end if there are
any questions i will take up and then i
can answer those
[Music]
you